this issue is important to me because
50% of truck Native American and I take
my heritage very seriously and I feel as
though throughout the years we've been
oppressed and kind of put on view by
most of the country and we were the
first people to inhabit this country and
we have a voice and we need to be
my mother always pushes me to be the
best role model I can be for my people
and I kind of take advantage of that you
know that platform to be a role model
and I just want to show them that
anything is possible even you know being
a native Native American in a white
man's world so to speak that it is
possible to play basketball or do
whatever it is that you want to do at
the highest level
I hope to accomplish just being here for
my people and like I said before
shedding a little more light on this
issue so it gets out there more because
only one or two of the right people need
to hear this message and have it resume
with them to you know make some change